Francis Arnold was born in 1956 in
Pittsburgh United States she got her PhD
in 1985 at the University of California
at Berkeley she is now active as a
professor at California Institute of
Technology in Pasadena also in
California
Francis Arnold pioneered directed
evolution of enzymes she used her
engineering skills to make this method a
most versatile tool for developing bio
catalysts for new environments and for
new tasks she has made a strong effort
to make this planet a better place the
enzyme she develops can be used to speed
up chemical reactions in a sustainable
way making less waste in a cleaner
process we call them fantastic
biocatalysts now Francis Arnold I invite
you to the stage to deliver your talk
okay
[Music]
thank you I'd like to thank the the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences the
Nobel Prize Committee in Chemistry my
family many of whom are here my friends
even more of whom are here and
especially I'd like to thank my former
and current students and I know there's
a group of you here because it's really
their contributions that I'll be talking
about today I'm a engineer I have been
in awe and mesmerized by the chemistry
of the biological world for some time
because it's this incredible diversity
of transformations that gives rise to
all the beauty and functionality that we
see in the natural world the complexity
of the products that nature makes and
when you think about how she can
assemble these products with ease and
elegance and remarkable efficiency from
simple renewable abundant starting
materials to me that's a real
inspiration for chemistry of the future
now who does this chemistry it's the
enzymes these remarkable marvelous
molecular machines that catalyze all the
reactions in the living world almost all
the reactions in the living world and
that our DNA encoded now I'm also in awe
and inspired by the enzymes but also by
the process that nature uses to create
them and in fact that nature uses to
create everything in the living world
evolution
it's a remarkable diversity generating
machine it's a simple algorithm of
mutation and natural selection that
gives you a recipe for adaptation for
optimization for innovation and has
created all the life that we see our
the starting from a Universal common
ancestor a simple life form more than
three billion years ago now I wanted to
build new enzymes and protein engineers
like I was in the 1980s we struggled
mightily with a simple problem and that
is we didn't understand and we still
don't today enough about how a DNA
sequence encodes function in order to be
able to reliably design a new enzyme
that's why I turn to nature's process so
here's the problem even today we can
read DNA we can write DNA you can just
email a sequence off to your favorite
supplier and you'll get it back in the
mail we can edit DNA CRISPR casts we
have all these tools but what we do not
know how to do and this is the problem
that I took on thirty years ago is how
do you compose it it's like a Beethoven
symphony the code of life it's intricate
it's beautiful but we don't know how to
write like that but nature does you have
this process so we can think of all the
proteins that exist today in fact all
the way back to the Universal common
ancestor as this set of proteins that
are relevant to biology biologists this
is what you study this little green
place because that is but an
infinitesimal fraction of the possible
proteins we can think of this universe
of all possible proteins as a playground
for the future this is where I want to
explore and I want to explore here
because I think the solutions to many of
humanity's biggest problems lie in this
space now this is a challenge of course
because this space is vast it's bigger
than the universe the number of
particles in the universe by many many
orders of magnitude
this remarkable short story by Jorge
Luis Borgess the library of Babel
describes for all practical purposes an
infinite library of all possible books
and the librarians there are in despair
how could I if I want to search this
universe of sequences which is like all
possible proteins but I know that most
of those possible books encode nothing
at all they're just gibberish these
random combinations of letters don't
compete with pumping oil out of the
ground for example how could I search
this library and find something
meaningful so this is a tough problem
because if you look at this space it's
so big and we've heard some very big
numbers in these experiments gazillions
well I cannot search for gazillions I
don't have tend to the gazillion
graduate students or even ten to the
ninth graduate students and if we look
at for a large protein now we've gone
from peptides to antibodies which can be
quite large but we go to something I can
enzyme that space of possibilities is
enormous if you make a single mutation
to a typical protein you have thousands
of ways to do that you start making too
and you have millions of ways you make
three and it just grows exponentially
we cannot search this the space just
without thinking a little bit about the
process now John Maynard Smith helped me
address this problem in a marvelous
paper that he wrote published in 1970 my
favorite one and a half page paper and
he said consider proteins in an ordered
space where every sequence is surrounded
by its neighbors that differ by one
mutation and he argued that if evolution
is to occur and he believes it does and
I think most of us here believe that
evolution happens functional proteins
have
to be distributed in this space so that
any functional protein something you can
scrape off your shoe is surrounded by
other at least a few other functional
proteins forming a network maybe sparse
in this space where most sequences are
gibberish forming a network where
evolution can walk along and that's
exactly what proteins have done for the
last three and a half billion years
they've accumulated mutations one at a
time primarily to create what the
proteins are today now of course I want
to make better proteins
I want to make enzymes that will solve
human problems so let me add one more
dimension to this and that is the
fitness the performance how an enzyme
performs a new job and that's defined by
me in this set of experiments and we can
think of this now as an optimization
problem on a fitness landscape now in
the 1980s we knew very very little about
the structure of this landscape it could
be rugged and if it's very rugged than
most mutations of deleterious and send
you into a crevasse of non function and
evolution is very hard in that case on
the other hand if it's smooth and John
Maynard Smith helped argue that it has
to be smooth in its dimensions for us to
be here to talk about it
then you can use simple optimization
processes now science like all human
endeavors is an evolutionary process
right it builds on what is there and
riri combine different pits and pieces
from different places and a lot of
interesting things were happening in the
1980's you've heard about some of those
and in the early 1990s for example
Manfred eigen was talking about
experimental molecular evolution and
Jerry Joyce was evolving RNA in the
laboratory directing the evolution of
RNA jeremy knowles showed us that
beneficial mutations and proteins could
be accumulated
Stuart Kaufmann was talking about the
theoretical fitness landscape searches
and then for me Dan Dennett a
philosopher gave me wonderful words and
framework for the ideas that I was
trying to work on and all of these came
together in a simple process now the
difference between my experiments and
those that you've heard about is that I
don't have an affinity selection that
lets me search through a million or ten
million or a billion different molecules
we have to measure them one by one
because you get what you scream for in
this business and if you're looking at
it enzyme you need to measure what that
enzyme does maybe we can test a few
thousand things or a few tens of
thousands of things most of those
mutations are deleterious so this meant
that we had to be very careful about how
we were going to carry out this
optimization making just a few mutations
at a time maybe one at a time randomly
in the molecule scream carefully to
measure the small effects that you would
expect to get from a single mutation and
then if you wanted something that was
very different from what you started
with and believe me choosing that
starting point is important because you
don't get a race horse from a donkey so
you choose that that's a very rational
thing if you want something quite
different from what you start with and
you have to iterate you have to
accumulate those mutations over multiple
generations and this gave us an
experimental process that has proven its
value so if you start with your donkey
and and most enzymes are pretty good
Nature has done a good job optimizing
them for their job but if you start
asking it to do a new job for me they're
less enthusiastic let's say and that
Fitness drops dramatically but on this
smooth Fitness landscape a simple
optimization of accumulating mutations
over multiple generations can reoptimize
it for the new job
that worked from the 1980s that we
started this culminated in this first
paper published in 1993 where Kevin Chen
showed that we could adapt an enzyme to
what was considered a highly non natural
environment fact it was so now not
natural that many biochemist told me oh
you can't do that it won't work
an enzyme will never work and dimethyl
formamide in fact they don't like it at
all but what we showed is that with a
few mutations and doing this process you
could convince it to work just as well
in 50 or 60 percent DMF as it was did in
its natural environment in 1995 I met
Tim stemmer shortly after his DNA
shuffling paper was published we met at
a workshop at the Santa Fe Institute and
I was taken with his vision he he
introduced this idea of sexual
recombination so this is another search
strategy for evolution seems to work
pretty well there's a lot of diversity
you get by recombining your DNA with
somebody else's and Pym talked about
this is a molecular breeding process and
I often use that when I present my work
now sadly PIM passed away in 2013 but he
started a company that pushed a lot of
this technology mine and his out into
the world and as a result of their work
at maxsa j'en and many many other
laboratories this directed evolution
process has created enzymes that you
will find in your laundry detergents
that are used to manufacture
pharmaceuticals that are used in all
sorts of different industries today I'm
very proud of those applications none of
which I'm responsible for but that's the
nice thing if you provide a basic
framework that's simple and this is what
engineers like to do make it as simple
as possible then the whole world will be
able to use it but we learned some very
interesting things about enzyme
in the process of doing that of course
they will adapt rapidly we didn't know
this at the time we didn't know how many
iterations how many mutations it would
take to get a new function out of an
enzyme or to make it function in a non
natural environment or take a new
substrate and those came rapidly we also
learned that we are a long ways away
from being able to design them because I
knew this process would be useful back
in the 90s because we knew it was fast
but also that the solutions that you got
were so surprising mutations happened
all over the protein 2030 angstroms away
from the active site where no one could
explain them much less predict them so
here we have this marvelous optimization
mechanism and that's what I've told you
about you take a a biological enzyme and
you can optimize it and change it for
different functions so now I'm going to
fast forward into today so that I can
end with the future I'm interested today
not in the optimization so much although
that's very important but actually how
does evolution create novelty how could
you create enzymes to catalyze reactions
you cannot even find in the biological
world or at least we haven't found them
yet you cannot go to a database and find
an enzyme that catalyzes your favorite
reaction how could we import reactions
even invented by human beings a hundred
years of creative chemistry how could we
import that into the efficiency of the
biological world in genetically encode
whole new chemistry and at first I
thought that would be a really hard
problem because we all know enzymes are
so beautifully designed they position
their functional groups to catalyze a
reaction and stabilize a transition
state and how do you create a whole new
active site it's a very conservative
process what I just described to you
making one mutation at a time but that's
the wrong way to think about it because
nature is making new enzymes all the
time usually to break down your bill and
billion
or antibiotic but usually in response to
pressures that humans have placed on
this planet so here's a great example a
potent herbicide that we've been dumping
into the environment onto our fields for
more than 60 years was first thought to
be non biodegradable and all of a sudden
some enzyme figured out how to
dechlorinate atrazine giving a rich
nitrogen source to the organism that
invented it and it spread all over the
world this is evolution in real time
evolution in real time every time you
see antibacterial soap we're causing and
pushing evolution but it's happening
quickly so how does this happen how do
you get evolution in real time well it
happens that enzymes already have those
capabilities
they're like graduate students you're
selected for working long hours at low
pay and you can do that but maybe you
could also play the piano or do dishes
if you had to if chemistry was no longer
a viable field for work you could go and
switch into something else what enzymes
are just like that any enzyme that
exists today has promiscuous
capabilities that evolution uses as a
fuel for further invention and if you
can find those promiscuous capabilities
I'm the trainer of molecules I have to
see those then you can use this simple
turn the crank
presto results process of directed
evolution so let me give you an example
I love the cytochrome C's because here's
a family of enzymes that Nature has
diversified to carry out all sorts of
interesting chemical reactions and many
of you are familiar these nature's uses
one or a set of closely related highly
reactive intermediates to do this and
presumably through this process of
mutation and selection has diversified
this family now we argued in looking at
this that wow this looks a little bit a
little bit like human invented chemistry
if you could convince a cytochrome p450
to create a reactive intermediate
that has a carbon these are reactive
carbons in the active site make an iron
carbonate maybe you could convince it to
transfer that and do human chemistry
like turn double bonds into
cyclopropanes or insert that carbon and
into an xh bond this is not known in the
biological world was invented by human
beings but if we provided the right
synthetic environment think atrazine
right a new niche for the enzyme and
this tool of directed evolution perhaps
we could create enzymes for these new
human things so it becomes a question
can a heme protein create these new
reactive intermediates and there was
some evidence that that would be
possible but then the hard part would it
take that instead of using it to chew
itself up would it transfer that to a
second substrate so now you've got to
have two substrates coming together in a
enzyme that's never seen these before
and if you can see that little bit of
activity does it evolve five years ago
we asked these questions that I'll just
give you one example of much more recent
work that we did in fact these do do
carbon transfer we've created a whole
bunch of carbon transfer aces and one of
the ones that I love to talk about is
one that does chemistry that even humans
have a really hard time doing making
highly strained carbon cycles like by
cyclo butane which is a transformation
not known in the biological world and
even in the chemical world the world of
human chemistry is very difficult to do
and it requires precious metals so iron
earth-abundant iron was never known to
do this but chi-chan showed that he
could make cyclopropanes we have more
than 50 kcals per mole of ring strain in
these structures and that by providing a
carbon precursor to this the enzyme
would form the reactive carbon transfer
it to that and the furthermore it
evolves so he discovered chitin
discovered an enzyme sitting in our
refrigerator I have a tremendous
collection of interesting him
and he just said can you do this as a
promiscuous activity then he showed he
could evolve it over multiple
generations to become reasonably
efficient catalyst but even more
wondrous is that he could further train
the enzyme to do it twice
so if it hangs on to this reactive
cyclopropane in the active site he can
now add a second carbon so you blow off
nitrogen with this that drives the
formation the carbon you can now add a
second it might by cyclobutane pure
diastereomers you only make one of the
four possible diastereomers because the
enzyme creates the environment where
this remarkable chemistry can take place
furthermore the enzymes can make lots of
by cyclobutane now as far as I know
nobody wants by cyclobutane if anybody
wants them please let me know but these
are interesting interesting molecules
that really have evaded human chemistry
but hear an enzyme just learned how to
do that in a few generations and they
happen inside living cells so you do
this chemistry just by providing the
substrates
to bacteria in a in a culture and
they'll see you out enough of these so
that we can get we can assign the
absolute stereochemistry let me give you
another example consider bonds that are
unknown in biology here we have silicon
an element that is so abundant on our
earth's crust and has never been found
bonded to carbon in the biological world
there are no carbon silicon bonds in
biology some people have wondered why
that's the case I'm not going to answer
that question but now they are found in
biology because if you go to my
refrigerator you can find proteins for
example from this hot salty pool in
Iceland from an organism that grew there
and that protein if you just search
through these that protein will take a
carbon precursor
and this silane dimethyl phenol silane
and insert the carbon into that silicon
hydrogen bond and make new organosilicon
compounds just a wild type protein no
one ever asked if nature could do it of
course these are not naturally abundant
compounds but nature is capable Nature
has the inherent capability to do or
igano silicon chemistry for tea
turnovers that's as good as the best
human-made catalyst just a natural
protein 97% of nantou selectivity oh and
by the way I just point out this is a
cytochrome C and it is so stable so
stable you can boil it even a chemist
can use it it's so stable it just looks
like a powder and it works beautifully
for this chemistry the native function
of this cytochrome C is electron
transfer and in fact if you know
anything about cytochrome C you'll be
puzzling whoa how does this happen
because the active site where this
chemistry takes place if you look at the
crystal structure of this protein you
see that the active site is all filled
up with protein it's the iron is fully
saturated all the ligands from the
porphyrin ring and the axial ligands
above and below just fill up the active
site so if you roll your little ball
over the computer you find a big fat 0 4
active site volume but Nature doesn't
care about your calculations because
this protein is perfectly happy to do
this chemistry and our pictures are
simple pictures of proteins don't do
justice of what's actually happen not
only does it do this chemistry but this
protein also evolves so that if you make
mutations near the active site over
three generations you can evolve the low
promiscuous activity of the wild protein
into something that now becomes dozens
of times better than the best human
catalyst just turn the crank give them a
little bit of sugar
and the proteins will evolve and it
works inside of bacterial cells why is
that important the bacterial cells will
make your catalysts and make millions of
versions of your catalysts for the price
of sugar so if it's DNA encoded and
these are all just you put the gene into
the bacteria if it's DNA encoded you can
just grow all the catalysts that you
want and mutate it a million times for
the price of sugar and here I show you
an example where for example you can
choose between putting that carbon in on
silicon or a nitrogen and if you've
evolved the catalysts it chooses only
the silicon so you get the chemo
selectivity enantioselective ax t all
done by the bacteria now when this story
was published went all over the world
because everybody said we're making
silicon-based life that wasn't the case
I don't have time to go into some of the
funny things that came about it but
apparently nobody actually read the
paper they only read the title of the
paper so it went around the world and
mutated the story as it went around the
world and and it gave my group a lot of
fun laughter reading the Twitterverse
interpretations of how we were creating
silicon-based life but it works in life
and you could conceivably build silicon
into living systems now that you have
genetically encoded chemistry you can
also learn how the protein learned how
to do this you could get the structure
of the protein and in this case we see
that the structure has changed
dramatically we have a loop over this
active iron that has completely flipped
out into solvent there were three
mutations that were made in this protein
has caused this loop to flip out and
opens up a volume a pocket here that has
sufficient volume now to accommodate a
large number of different substrates
and do this chemistry extremely
efficiently dozens of times better than
the best catalyst that was ever
published by a human being if you can do
it with silicon you can do it with other
atoms as well and so for example
recently a year later we we just
published excuse me the incorporation of
carbons into boron
h bonds and yes there are no boron
carbon bonds found in the biological
world and here's a bond that's very much
favored by chemists very versatile
system organ abhorrent but you can take
an enzyme or a protein like cytochrome C
and just turn the crank so you're
starting to get a little bit of the
pattern here you discover a little bit
of activity you have this wonderful
optimization problem process and we can
find by starting with the zero
generation wild-type protein and
evolving over three generations you now
have something that when you use it
under optimal conditions is four hundred
times better than the best human
catalyst for the same reaction does it
with earth-abundant
iron and you can of course also change
the selectivity tuning the catalyst for
the chemistry that you're interested in
I just point out that in the biological
world one criticism we face if we want
to do biocatalysis is that oh you can't
do what I can do I have great chemists
at Caltech who can do and create
materials that biological world can't do
but I hope that's going to change
because I've just shown you even though
biology is limited to the bonds that it
can make so carbon for example is often
found bonded to nitrogen or oxygen or
sulfur a little bit to the halogens a
few other things lots of lots of
hydrogen of course but there's vast
portions of the periodic table that it
we have never found a biological system
to do and I just showed you in the
of two years we've added two whole
elements to biologies repertoire so you
can now build carbon boron and carbon
silicon scaffolds in living systems and
of course then do further chemistry on
that in metabolic pathways so I would
like to leave you with this idea for the
future because I'm I'm really excited
about now but even more so about the
future of this science that we have this
incredibly powerful design algorithm
right it works at all scales from
molecules to ecosystems and it not only
optimizes but it can innovate and it can
do it in real time and in the chemistry
world what that does is open this
opportunity basically to take down the
barrier between the natural chemistry
and human invented chemistry and just
import all those human inventions into
the biological world you just sit there
and I sit there and read chemistry
papers my students read old Jack's
journals and they say wow I bet I could
import this reaction in and I haven't
shown you many of the other ones that
they've been successful in doing but
this is an exciting thing I think for
the young people people because by
marrying these different fields it's
it's like you're in a a goldmine of
possibilities that you can now
genetically encode and make much easier
some of your favorite chemistry and I'd
also like to leave you with this idea
that the biological world is wonderfully
diverse there is a bazillion proteins
out there just waiting to solve your
problem and nature knew this right the
Internet of Things now now it's the
Internet of living things that's been
crowdsourcing problem solving for more
than 3 billion years and if we learn how
to use this to our benefit we can move
into a much more sustainable future and
make our fuels and chemicals using
biological systems
so I'd like to leave you with this idea
that we have a universe to explore we
have a spaceship for exploring that
universe it's called evolution and I
want to thank the very large number of
people who've worked with me over the
years at Caltech a big fraction of them
are shown in this picture they came for
one of my big birthdays a couple of
years ago and once again I thank them
and I thank you for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
Frances Arnold George Smith and Gregor
winter thank you all for wonderful talks
and I now welcome all three of you up on
the stage to take all their places
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]